in einer passage auf der unten sind ja
du hast ja auch das einstein schwer du
kannst auch ein auf dicker machen
hallöchen alle miteinander und herzlich
willkommen zurück zur capt main kreft 24
zusammen mit goma hatten in der höhe und
in der letzten folge haben wir wieder
ein paar ski fans geknackt wir sehen
hier wir sind schon viel näher an der
neuen leiter und alle möglichen sachen
zurück walter ja ich habe gesagt ich
habe ja auch grün schon zu dir gesagt
komm ich könnte dir mal das ich hier mit
der feldjacke ich komme ich denke ich
werde das ganze verpacken mit der
rangliste so ein bisschen
wir haben auch in der letzten folge sag
mal was wir unten entdeckt haben was
haben wir unten entdeckt wir haben
einander person shooter auf der unten
sind ja du hast ja auch das einstein
schwer du kannst auch ein dicker machen
eben eben leben
das hat meine familie ich bin so froh
ist der weg nun ja hier schon mal hier
ich habe eisen gefunden noch mal top
okay wir haben hier nämlich sondern so
einen supertollen mein chef gefunden
also wenn wir hier gut nach unten laufen
setzt man hier da braucht man sich
überlegt millionen ist schon eine fackel
hier sehen wir steht nix mehr aber hier
sehen wir das ist mein chef war und hier
oben ist auch noch holz und das haben
wir gleich mitgenommen wie blöd sind
eigentlich sollte stehen das ja meint
moment ich habe doch gar keinen roten
sand mitgenommen aber wir haben ja keine
axt eine axt will gut wandern gut das
hätte auch wir holz gebaut hätten der
genaue habe ich auch gedacht so legen
wir jetzt andere hier auch noch mit
anderen bauen oder wollen wir erstmal
sagen wir erkunden die etage und schauen
dann später willst wirklich diese etage
erkunden da hinten ist ein spinnennetz
bonner genau wir müssen irgendwann auch
weiter machen und ich finde aber nicht
stimmt das denn hier geht ja gar nicht
heute auf der anderen seite von 1
siehst du das holz ja und hier ist ja
auch schon die bordon müssen weiter
runter das liegt aber auf der anderen
seite das holz ich muss da jetzt rein
komme ich muss da rein kommt die
rangieren hier hier ist doch nicht herum
ich hab's ich hab's ich hab's du hast
das bauer gut so wollen wir einfach
schnell runter ich würde sagen die
zahlen nur ganz kurz mit mainz ist es na
ja zumindest diesen beiden da hätte ich
irgendwann die kühe oben besser einbauen
kann weiß er stimmt ja vielleicht hätte
ich den glas- oder mehr als kann man
nicht mehr rein gucken aber doch wir
können eine öffnung wir machen und
darüber lachen können ich bin ja durch
neven man hier den hier macht nicht ja
genau das mache ich mit dem zaun ok
super dann willst du weiter nach unten
doch warum nicht wo wollen wir es machen
stimmt in diese richtung geht auch nicht
mehr viel da mache ich das hier jetzt
mal wieder eine abzweigung wir können ja
später auch einfach so just for fun
schilder aufbauen ja ich denke mal eben
dafür heute nach oben nicht dass ich
irgendwie sterbe und das hier stimmt
stimmt für straßenschilder nach dem
motto kommt noch alles wo ich hab ne
neue höhle gefunden okay ich gehe aber
noch nicht rein
ich warte noch auf dich hören skelett
ich muss irgendwie du musst mir gleich
mal helfen weil ich sehe auch nichts was
ich komm hoch und ich habe ja auch nur
noch hold ich habe ihm nur ein
holzschwert kommerzielle einzigen cent
schon stadt hat der einzige bei uns der
einzige von uns beiden der innenstadt
hatte ich bin bei dir wo l niveau bis
tun
ich bin doch schon nach oben gegangen
kommt diese tür so knuffig ist geil
dann lege ich da mal kurz die zäune rein
die eichenholz blätter dann in richtung
mit kongo kommen wir von gummi acombo
heute an und bestellen sie bei uns eine
in eine richtung wie blöd wir sind guck
mal hinter diesen moment teilen sind
fackeln
die hätten uns einfach mitnehmen kann
und welche zu kräften brauchen wir auch
nicht
ach ja stimmt ja dann setzen wir
vielleicht ein erinnern sondern reicht
das für eine beleuchtung
das ist ja genau hier kommt mit fackeln
hier sind ja stimmt
was wohl als nächstes machen wir runter
in die höhe die ich gerade entdeckt habe
oder oder was ich schaue mal ganz kurz
bei den erfolgen
buck brot la blabla ich glaube wir
müssen wirklich uns langsam wieder in
die höhle begeben und schauen was da
unten noch alles gibt
okay vielleicht wenn wir gleich
diamanten finden diesen trend auf jeden
fall wieder
ich gehe mal eben hoch und fiel noch mal
die suppen auf ja was uns allen hier
sind nee ich hab mir ich hab wegstück
hier kann auch welche geben sieben sogar
nicht mal jetzt lernen noch
ich schaue schon gerade die ganze zeit
was kann man sich dann doch wir machen
was herumliegt ich kombiniere hat immer
mal so ein bisschen soll die strecke
haben wir ein roter sand da ist nur holz
spitzhacke ich nehme dir einfach mal mit
ja was ist hier sonst noch so aus dem 24
ich weiß nicht was wir mit diesem 24
toren soll nicht aus ein paar habe ich
ja schon diese blöcke gemacht wenn man
brater kann man braten und mit farbe
kombinieren später eventuell stimmt das
grab ist dazu wie kann man das doch
recht fern oder kann man braten dann
erhält man so einen besonderen play
daraus aber kann man das wirklich
glauben wir haben kann man es nicht
schon wieder 12 meisten nicht braten das
muss man den kräftigen bereich liegen
wie wenn man eine werkbank macht macht
das ruhig mal okay ja das habe ich mit
den anderen auch schon gemacht
so haben jetzt haben wir elf ton einfach
das laden und wie mit was müssen wir
also zu legen ja und dann haben wir dann
dann brannten nieder so ein bridgestone
weißt du sowie eine hauswand sieger aus
so haben wir damit machen weiß ich nicht
also kann man noch abwarten
der hätte fahrradkette ich weiß nicht
was man noch machen könnte
erst wenn die hülle oder ok weiter
runter ich bin ich möchte mir ein
hollenstein schwert machen die war ich
immer angst machen wenn wir in höhe
waren und holz gut haben aber ein stick
ist hier sogar noch
wenn man sich das ist ein stick komme
ich mache jetzt ebenso ich habe jetzt
ein stein schwer
jetzt fühle ich mich auch ein ganz klein
bisschen sicherer eisenstädter machen
können wir zwei sticks sechs holz mir
kommt das also erstmal bewahren nicht
dass wir nachher noch ein amboss
brauchen weiß vorliegen hat immer lieben
ok
mit komm einfach mal weiter in die höhe
nach unten
das immer ein bisschen blöd mit hope
weitergeht sollte man hier irgendwie
eine faktische ich jetzt mal hier eine
fackel hin nicht nur so also ich glaube
auch da unten wird und dass auch wieder
kohle gut stellt du dich mal westen nach
dauer und umfang die kohle auf die ich
jetzt abbauen sich so dass nee da wo ich
ab ich warte warte warte auch da bist du
ja hab ich nicht auf da unten liegt hier
kaum hat da hier seien stellten schwer
zu direkten angriffen
hast du die kurve habe ich kein super
weiter nach unten jetzt auch wieder kolo
gut also ich denke an kohle wird uns
wird uns nicht haben am verbrennen dann
verbrennen am besten nicht mit holz
sondern mit kohle war ich möchte
irgendwann auch bäume und nicht die
ganze spitze gekappt jetzt gerade wenn
wir erreichen
wenn wir einen baum hätten dann wäre ich
so glücklich wenn ich eine hätte ich
hoffe wirklich dass wir das durch
monument wir bekommen das wir doch
echten traum wenn wir da bekommen soll
ich mal eine fackel hinsetzen hier
eventuell nicht aber noch mal ganz kurz
für die aufnahme bauarbeiter fordern
film ich dich dabei ist ihr guck mal
hier
da das sind auch rote pilze viren
minenschacht solche mal gucken was man
ganz vorsichtig beim thema kurzweg die
seiten freibauern euro so schätzt es
dass zum thema self könnt ihr immer noch
von hier kommen erwarte gehen wir weg da
jetzt will ich erstmal drin safe so
jetzt müssen nämlich immer wieder
überlegen
hier ist auch wer nicht viel aber hier
ist holz ich nehme platz damit einfach
guck mal hier oben kann man holz abbauen
und auf der anderen seite
ja ich nehme das von anderer seite mit
dann nehme ich mir auch mal die seite
mit die wir durch das spinnennetz
bekommen
genau so wie viel hast du das auch 303
ja genau
gut warte ich habe jetzt auch gleich
jeden moment 3 dann kann mir theoretisch
eigentlich auch da wieder weiter in die
nächste richtung geldwäsche weg gewählt
dass eine hexe das häckseln ja die steht
da einfach nur rummel ist der
eventuellen truhe
das geht dann nach links weiter bei dem
gang wir müssen da lang wollen wir
erstmal das holz safe und kurz oben
können wir müssen sicher auf sich damit
aber nicht ja ich nehme an hitze und das
das wichtigste erstmal gibt mir alles
außer dein schwert und spitzhacke was
fackeln und was auch alles mit habe ich
kehre gut ich gehe eben nach oben wieder
ich zeig mal die sachen pass auf das
jetzt aber nicht nicht irgendwie zehn
millionen kisten öffnen alles was ich
jetzt fühle ich bin mit der hexe gerade
im gefecht ja du schaffst wahrscheinlich
glaube ich und gehe ein schlag hat sie
bekommen wie viele braucht sie du kannst
noch tipps abgeben noch warten noch vier
noch vier ok moment 28 grad oben
angelangt dritter treffer
vierter treffer am rande hexe fünfte
treffer okay ich habe noch ein paar
bisschen fackeln gemacht dass noch eine
hexe das sind einfach zwei hexen zwei
stücke auf einem haufen so ich hab genug
sachen wir können jetzt mir das richtig
viel kämpfen ich habe es dort richtig
bock auf kämpfen und alles auch tod
eines tot
ich komme ich kann mich kaum erwarten
wenn du keine angst ich komme jetzt
nicht vergiftet gehen zurück geht es los
denn er macht nichts ich kann ja eh
nicht an vergiftung sterben jetzt würde
ich sie okay sie ist tot
okay ich hab nur gerade noch die gang
du hast nichts verpasst also hexen
ankämpfen zog hier haben wir bald wie
reisen
ok klassischen wir hier die world water
erstmal wieder zu bauen nicht dass
dadurch noch welche rein kommen immer
mal so hier ist noch so ein bisschen
seide das auch wieder holz ok super holz
hier haben wir mittlerweile wieder ein
bisschen können uns ja schon mal die
feldtage machen oder machte allerdings
auch ein eisen schwert wollen wir
wirklich ein eisen schwert machen ja ich
meine es ist zwar nur ein stick und zwei
eisen aber das ist ja nicht unbedingt
nötig komme aber schon effektiv ja
natürlich aber dabei ein reisebuch
spitzhacke erst mal effektiver weil ich
habe jetzt gar keine spitzhacke mir eben
gemacht dann machen wir das als macher
seid ihr holz erst recht erst recht so
warte ich nur noch in die kohle mit das
ist ja erneut mit der stadt abbauen und
dann gehen wir nach oben machen uns die
feldtag und dann ist schon wieder der
pfad vorbei dann ist der nächste partner
wieder beim können mich in offenen
kanälen
da bin ich auch heute
er komme weiter dass er der gome ist
alter also solle wahrheit
du hast das lactase ich habe eine lange
mono braue wenn darauf achtet ist nein
ich hab ich drauf der durch schluckauf
werke würden wir kommen so haben wir
holz vergessen die hier sind nur noch
zögern ich habe einfach mal na gut 20
nehme die zahl noch mit für die kühe
oben
dann setzt sich einfach roten sand
stattdessen hin ich glaube da haben
sogar genug um die einzuzahlen
dann können wir das eventuell auch noch
schnell in meinen part machen wenn der
pass noch zulässt obwohl sollte endlich
tun so eben schnell nach oben jumpen wir
machen das alles noch schön wenn wir
erst mal ein bisschen mehr ressourcen
wir wollen jetzt natürlich nicht unsere
spitzhacke dafür ausgeben das ganze
schön zu machen
seitdem am anfang schon gut gesagt wo
ich meine kommen dass noch alles klar
machen sieht schöner aus ton aber nehmen
wir müssen natürlich darauf achten dass
ich die spitzhacke nicht so stark
abgenutzt ich muss auch sagen ich habe
hier noch fast gar keine frame einbruch
gehabt irgendwie noch nie so richtig
krass gehen wie mal geruckelt
so etwas hier oben gut wenn jetzt packt
die sachen da rein
das heißt ich mache jetzt so wo bist du
ich komm ich komme was ich habe noch
acht leitern comedy keine leitern ich
hab noch zäune ja so dass das mit farben
haben wir schon gemacht
das segment mit ist mit der ja die haben
wir doch schon stimmt was wollte ich
gerade machen ich glaube ich wollte
sagte du wolltest eine spitzhacke machen
daher stimmt komm sag mal ein ganz
kurzer zickzack ich hoch zu den pilz
grüne sah ich habe eine eisen spitzhacke
ich leg sie erstmal in die truhe
damit das nicht passiert dann sah ich
kann manchmal ganz kurz hoch mit zu den
kühen damit ich sehe da hast du die
zeilen mitgenommen ich habe acht von
unten dabei okay ich hab auch noch neun
machen dass man ein größeres gehege
machen falls für die pan oder nicht das
ist ja erst mal können wir immer noch
erweitern dass man die stück für stück
schauen dass die zäune reich schauen auf
jeden fall dass er keiner stadt ab so
schlägt es knapper direkt ineinander
wer denn nun richtig viel bei mir die
sind richtig traurig darüber dass wir
sie eingesperrt haben bei mir auf und
haben auch schon lernen blick guck mal
ich hab gar keine chance mehr
also für ein großes gehege also ich habe
nicht genug ein großes leiter der wahl
heftig wie anfällig grass oder seine
schöne rasiere ich bin drin
dann kommt es nicht mehr raus dadurch
habe ich warte ja ok oder so da draußen
okay wir haben die kühe eingezogen wir
haben das haben wir nicht geschafft ich
weiß gar nicht und bald kommen wir hier
zu der leiter und da ist auch anderes
holz dessen alter dass er richtig viel
holz
wo ich dachte warum ist mit ruhe drauf
und das richtig viel holz alternativ mit
1 234 holz wieder okay cool ich denke an
holz wird uns erst mal nicht aber wir
müssen auf jeden fall vorsichtig mit
unseren sachen umgehen
ich hoffe dass irgendwann erde und
einsätzen kommt er also die nächste
folge kommt bei ghom auf dem kanal wenn
es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
selber einen daumen hoch freuen
und ihr könnt uns weiterhin noch tipps
ist er in die kommentare schreiben oder
irgendwas und dann ist die nächste folge
morgen auf dem kanal